I first learned about this seven years ago on a
mission in brazil to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore
through our unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
It had the
same marking you do cole it's a birthmark
what do you mean he was born with it it's not
a birthmark cole means you've been chosen
throughout history different cultures all
over the world reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking i think it's
an invitation to fight for something known
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonya
that's kano i'm lui kang name's jax
Kung lao
the fate of earth is in our hands
no matter how many of my
people you put in the ground
we will not fail kill them
i am sub zero
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
mortal kombat trailer video flawless victory
they have all the hits in there for anybody who
was there for the original movie and played the
game since the very first title there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs we know a lot about what's
going on with the characters so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will be doing
videos for this movie when it comes out in april
but the synopsis just reads mma fighter cole
young played by louis tan here the one who's
just finding out about his mortal kombat tattoo
seeks out earth's greatest champions in order
to stand against the enemies of outworld
in a high-stakes battle for the universe
so it's the same basic pitch of the original movie
of the original story they're starting with the
outworld tournament with shang tsung but even if
you're not super familiar with the mythology of
mortal kombat as you probably guessed from the
title mortal kombat resurrection and all the
flashbacks scorpion scenes from before he became
scorpion a lot of the movie revolves around the
plot of scorpion's resurrection so the whole thing
about mortal kombat is that obviously it's based
on a tournament arc but the mythology goes really
deep in everybody every big bad that you see like
shang tsung everybody works for someone even more
evil and even more powerful like they even have
their own version of thanos inside the mortal
kombat universe for instance the next big bag
after shang tsung appears during the trailer xiao
khan he's sort of subservient to him even though
shang tsung himself is something of a big bad but
even though it's an ensemble cast with a bunch of
different characters everybody has their favorite
mortal kombat character of all the mains the pov
character is mostly the cole young character
played by louis tan who i actually believe early
theory here is a descendant of scorpion because if
the plot revolves around scorpion's resurrection
and he has no memory of who he is and where the
mortal combat tattoo comes from it just seems
like he's connected to all the scorpion stuff
that's happening in the trailer even though they
didn't identify all of them on screen most of you
could probably tell who most of these characters
are but i'll just go through shot by shot we'll
talk about easter eggs so they start with the
voice over narration of sonia blade talking to ko
young about a mission that she went on and then
they show you the mission in flashbacks with her
and jax before he got his bionic arm going after
sub-zero without really knowing that they were
going after sub-zero he freezes his arm and breaks
it off like it's a piece of tissue paper like it's
no big deal so you have to remember this movie is
kind of a soft reboot of the movie franchise there
have been a couple mortal kombat movies although i
would recommend that you just stop with the first
one they made sequels but unless you are a mortal
combat stan or you just really really want to i
would not recommend watching them this version of
sub-zero is supposed to be the original sub-zero
b-han who actually winds up becoming noob saibot
in the mythology of mortal kombat that doesn't
wind up happening until much later the whole
thing with scorpion and sub-zero in their rivalry
is that scorpion believes that sub-zero the bihan
character here is responsible for killing him and
his entire clan like you see the flashbacks here
with this character hiroki sonata this is scorpion
before he became scorpion was killed and then
resurrected his name while he was still alive was
hanzo hasashi so he's the member of the scorpion
clan that's just one of their weapons that they
use for fighting obviously we all remember it from
all the games one of my favorite characters
to play with because of his special attack
he winds up killing bihan the sub-zero character
but then later finds out that he was actually
deceived by this other elder god of the mortal
kombat universe who's actually responsible for
killing his clan and his family but i don't know
how crazy they're gonna get with the mythology
because there are elder gods there are titans and
then there's like this giant thanos level over
god that's trying to reassemble a bunch of
gemstones and pieces of his soul together
doesn't that sound a little bit familiar didn't we
have a super big bag trying to change the universe
this is sort of multiverse aspect of the mortal
kombat story so imagine avengers infinity war with
thanos trying to assemble the infinity gauntlet
but imagine it's across the multiverse i'm pretty
sure they're not gonna get into that during this
first mortal combat movie like i said it's just
based on introducing this initial tournament
arc with shang tsung and then eventually we'll
probably meet shao khan as some of the bigger
villains they do intend to make sequels so they
got to give themselves some place to go there are
several other big bads that are more powerful than
shang tsung in the mortal kombat universe later
in the trailer when you see scorpion in his full
scorpion gear fighting sub-zero and he says come
over here he actually does his special attacks
it's the same character but at that point he's
been resurrected one of the big bads the elder
god of chaos destruction is basically trying
to manipulate him while this is all happening
before he actually learns the truth of what really
went on so some of these characters are pawns of
the more powerful evil characters and because
i didn't mention it before the movie is rated
r if you couldn't tell from the red band at the
beginning of this so it will be rated r when they
released it on hbo max love the way they freeze
over the new line logo because it's all about
this rivalry between scorpion and sub-zero and
what happened to scorpion in all these flashbacks
they explained the mortal kombat tattoos part
of the mythology explains why certain people are
quote-unquote special in the moral combat universe
so a long time ago basically the elder gods wound
up killing this one over god figure like the one
true god of the mortal combat universe and split
his body into a bunch of different pieces those
different pieces became the different universes
like the universe of earth where we are right
now that's called earth realm but because that
one god was so powerful his essence sort of imbued
different people in each of these different realms
those people became the ones that were chosen
for the mortal kombat tournament so that kind
of explains where these special abilities come
from like some of them look like they have legit
special powers this person you see walking here is
molina clearly from the twin size she's probably
walking across outland you don't see her face till
later in the trailer but you do get that full-on
game animation style shot like that's literally
taken from a shot that you see in one of the games
when sonya blade is talking about the tournament
itself and they show you that picture that looks
ancient of the figure standing over a defeated foe
that's actually the great kung lao he's one of the
former greatest members of the tournament but he's
basically the great great great grandfather many
many times removed of liu kang and both kung lao
so kung lao and luke kang are somewhat related
but very very distantly this is raiden meeting
shang tsung this is a flashback of scorpion as
he's slowly getting resurrected like you see the
fire all around him his face is all messed up
that's kind of what he looks like without his mask
on these are obviously all the flashback scenes
that explain how he was betrayed and then killed
these are the mains walking through outland for
what looks like the first time like you see him
walking around in jeans and a t-shirt but it's not
all the mains but from left to right you have kano
liu kang sonia blade and then cole young remember
cole young is an original name for the movie like
i said i believe he's secretly somebody else he's
secretly the descendant of the real scorpion they
give you a once-over with the characters you see
jax once he's got his metal arms then raiden
shows up and sort of explains what the stakes
are explains how they're basically battling for
the fate of earth realm the whole reason for the
tournament is that originally these over gods
of the mortal kombat universe envisioned that
what would happen is is they were slowly trying to
reassemble all the pieces of the multiverse into
one realm and if you wind up beating another realm
in the tournament like if goro winds up winning
the tournament for shang tsung outland wins the
tournament over earth from then they gain the
right to basically merge earth realm with outland
the whole idea is that eventually you'll have
one realm that winds up winning the entire thing
they'll reassemble all the realms into one single
realm and that will assemble all the pieces of
this original older elder god so make it infinity
stones but instead it's different universes we
see the resurrected scorpion with his full powers
getting ready to start this all-out brawl with
sub-zero this is another shot of scorpion from
before he gets resurrected this is the new version
of shang tsung who's manipulating everything at
least at this stage in the tournament you probably
know at least some version of him from all the
games we get to see most of the characters use
some measure of their special abilities the whole
thing with cole young though i'll be interested
to see if he really is the descendant of scorpion
if he winds up finding a way to use the special
attack the scorpion uses we get our first shot
of goro getting ready to smash the hell out of
someone and obviously it's been a hot minute
since that first mortal kombat movie came out
so the special effects for goro just a little
little bit better than that original movie but it
is nostalgic to go back and watch the original now
love the way they in the trailer with scorpion
special a remix of the original mortal kombat
theme music and then obviously you have that tag
scene with kano kano wins we also gotta finish
him from shang sung during the trailer too so
pretty much all the iconic lines and dialogue
and characters from the original game the original
story are in here but like i said they went really
crazy with the mythology in the last 10 to 15
years so if you haven't played the mortal kombat
games since the original don't worry if they wind
up getting sequels which i believe they're hoping
to they'll probably progress through the mythology
at a pretty decent pace but everybody post
all your reactions in the comments below if you
spotted any really big easter eggs that i didn't
mention in the video my full Wandavision episode
7 video is gonna post friday so make sure you
have alerts enabled you don't miss any of those
everyone click here for my Wandavision episode 7
trailer video and click here for that brand new
justice league snyder cut trailer video so many
big trailers dropping now thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and flawless victory!